the facts just the facts it is an
annoying personal habit because people
want to tell you their opinion I think
this I know but tell me the facts first
then we'll do your opinion thought
hospice hospitalizations clucked down
still in the eighteen thousand but a
click down good news that's a fact
there's a fact that is good news my
opinion
you see flattening of the curve all
these new expressions that we never used
before Plateau flattening rounding net
change in hospitalizations down that's
good news three-day rolling average
because remember any one of these days
of reporting this is a new reporting
system its imprecise I wouldn't bet the
farm on any one days numbers but a 3 day
average starts to be a little more
accurate ICU admissions is down that's
good news
intubations are down that's very good
news just on a real life level when a
person is intubated they're on a
ventilator eighty percent of the people
will never come off the ventilator or
there abouts so that's good news a
little reality check you still have on a
day-to-day basis about two thousand
people who are being diagnosed with
kovat so we're out of the woods know
we're still in the woods the good news
is we show that we can change the curve
good news is great news in my opinion we
can control the spread that is great
news because can you imagine if we
couldn't control the spread if we did
all this and the spread kept going up so
we can control the spread but you still
have about two thousand people a day who
are new diagnosis
coming into the hospital system so it's
still a serious public health issue
lives lost yesterday 752 which is the
painful news of our reality day after
day and they are in our thoughts and
prayers
you see 707 and hospitals 45 in nursing
homes people are interested in about in
that and those numbers and how those
numbers are changing but you see the
terrible news has basically been flat
over the past several days again the
number of death is a quote unquote
lagging indicator
it's almost disrespectful to put it in
scientific terms but these are people
who were probably intubated they were on
a ventilator and then again a period of
time on a ventilator normally has a bad
outcome the total losses total number of
deaths number the CDC changed guidelines
on how they want information reported
they want death so and then another
category of probable deaths which is a
new category that's done by the local
Department of Health or the coroner so
we're going to rationalize those new
reporting requirements with local
governments and get that information out
as soon as we can
we're also since we have a little bit of
a period to take a breath we're going to
contact nursing homes and facilities to
find out if there were other people who
passed from kovat who were not
necessarily in a hospital or in a
nursing home because there is a sense
that there may be additional people who
have passed away and they weren't
included in the count because they
weren't in a hospital they weren't
nursing home so we'll be going through
that but basically the healthcare
situation has stabilized the fears of
overwhelming the healthcare system has
not happened thanks to the phenomenal
work of our frontline workers thanks to
all the additional capacity that the
hospital system created over 50 percent
additional capacity in one month just
think of that thanks to the work that
our federal government did Army Corps of
Engineers providing the beds of jabots
and comfort by the way Javits which is
2,500 bed capacity is the overflow valve
about 800 people have gone through
jabots so thank you very much and that
was a great service that was done by the
federal government in a very short
period of time so we have that
stabilized people are still getting
infected but we have the infection
spread down to a manageable number we've
accomplished that people are restless we
have to get talked about the reopening
of the economy how do we do this we have
to build a bridge from where we are to
the reopening of the economy well what
does that look like let's say that the
where we're going it's not a reopening
in that we're going to open what was
we're going to a different place and we
should go to a different place and we
should go to a better place if we don't
learn the lessons from this situation
then all of this will have been in vain
we learned a lot if we're willing to
open our eyes and open our ears so we're
going to a different place which is a
new normal and we talked about the new
normal we've been talking about the new
normal for years we're going to have a
new normal on public health by the way
the way we have a new normal and
environment
in economics and new normal and civil
rights and new normal and social justice
right this is the way of the world now
we're moving to a new place more
challenging place but also potentially a
better place
well when is this over I say personal
opinion it's over when we have a vaccine
it's over when people know I'm 100% safe
and I don't have to worry about this
when does that happen
when we have a vaccine when do we have a
vaccine 12 to 18 months who determines
that the federal government has to test
the vaccine FDA it's a big gap 12 to 18
months yes I say the sooner the better
anything we can do to work with the
federal government to get the vaccine
done faster we are all in it you want to
use New York State as a laboratory we
are ready willing and able any way the
New York State Department of Health can
work with the FDA to reduce that testing
period we are all in and energized and
creative and ambitious about it and so
anything we can do to accelerate that
vaccine we will do you need a place to
test it in large numbers think of New
York but that's the ultimate end right
we have a vaccine now we don't have to
worry about this by the way we'll
probably have to worry about the next
public health risk at that time so don't
forget everything we learned
besides the vaccine there's a
possibility that they develop a medical
treatment so we can't prevent you from
getting the virus but we have a new
medical treatment and if you get the
virus don't worry it's no big deal you
go when you get this medical treatment
that's another way of having a natural
end right and that's what convalescent
plasma is all about and the antibody
testing to find people who had the
antibody and then injecting the antibody
into a person as a treatment method may
be the hydroxychloroquine works now this
has been a very politicized topic I have
done my best to stay 100 miles away from
politics in all of this
if I drew everybody wants to see
hydroxychloroquine work everybody
well the president says he believes it
works but he's not a doctor you're right
he believes says he believes it works
but he's not a doctor find out find out
and everyone hopes that it works and
anything New York can do to test it we
will we are now testing
hydroxychloroquine there are a number of
hospitals that are doing it it's not a
government decision it's not a political
decision the medical doctor decides and
if a medical doctor decides it works
fine we have an executive order that
limits the prescription of
hydroxychloroquine only because we don't
have enough and there was such a demand
on it that people who need it and we're
using it can't get it so if the federal
government sends us more we will
dispense more it's a pure supply supply
side issue or maybe they develop another
drug that they figure out has an effect
that could happen between now and the
vaccine and we all pray that it does but
until you have the vaccine until you
have the medical treatment what do you
do
how are you building the bridge well
it's going to be a phased reopening
right and during the phase to reopening
the priority is make sure you do no harm
and keep your eye on the public health
issue that is what is key in all of this
so it's going to be a calibration of
reopening based on public health safety
and that infection rate because what we
have done and the reducing of the
infection rate is a pure function of
what New Yorkers have done and what
people of course the country have done
when you relax that social distancing
you could very well see an increase in
the infection rate so it's all a
calibration to the public health but
it's going to be a gradual increasing of
economic activity in calibration with
the public health public health
standards
the single best tool to doing this
gauging right is large-scale testing
test trace and isolate just what
everybody's talking about what does this
mean
means you test you find a positive you
trace back who they were with where they
were test those people and you isolate
the people who are positive it's in our
doable it's just very very hard to do
and it opens this new world of testing
and this new world of testing is a new
world to all of us by the way there's
diagnostic testing are you positive or
negative there's then testing for
antibodies were you exposed if I find
out that you were already exposed and
you had the virus now you can go back to
work because you had the virus you have
antibodies antibody testing what you
have the antibodies let's you can help
develop convalescent plasma where they
can take your blood
take those antibodies use it as
treatment there's saliva testing which
is faster and easier it's not blood
testing it's not a swab
it's just saliva but that's a new form
of testing that's just being developed
this finger prick testing which is less
invasive but also being developed this
full blood sampling testing which is
obviously more intrusive but to do the
testing you need testing equipment you
need swabs you need vials and you need
all of these things at a capacity that
does not now exist where do you do the
testing we've been doing testing in
hospitals frankly that's not a great
place to do testing you don't want
people walking into a hospital emergency
room who may be positive for Kovac our
drive-through locations are better but
how do you bring that to scale all right
and then even if you have the equipment
and the testing site and the personnel
to do the testing whether you
the labs to test all of these tests this
is a whole world of questions that
nobody has ever seen before the bottom
line is well you need large-scale
testing let's do it we can't do it yet
that is the unvarnished truth
I know because New York has been doing
this since they started exploring this
new world we are have done more tests
than any other state we've done over
500,000 tests which is more than the
other states that are near us combined
okay so we've been very aggressive here
but in all this time we've only done
500,000 tests now that's a large number
of tests yes but this is over one month
period and even 500,000 tests you're
talking about a state with 19 million
people right so you get a sense of the
the scale of what we have to do here we
cannot do it without federal support and
I've been saying this for days if you
have a state that has a lower need yes
they may be able to do it but when you
have a state that has to do a large
number of these tests I'm telling you we
can't do it without federal support and
I've said that from day one we will
coordinate and we have been coordinating
all the tests in our state that's how we
got to that five hundred thousand number
more aggressive than I think anyone else
we have 228 private laboratories in this
state we will coordinate with them we'll
make sure that we're not competing with
ourselves because there are a lot of
groups that are now testing New York
State Department of Health developed
their own antibody test and that test
is going to be very important and it's
in our control because we'll actually do
those tests we don't need a private lab
we don't need anyone else with those
tests it will go to about 2,000 per day
capacity and that is a finger prick test
so it's not terribly invasive even I can
endure the pain of that one we've asked
the FDA to approve a state test that
could get us to 100,000 people per day
to give you an idea that's then 500,000
a week if you don't work the weekends I
don't know if you do raise something I
don't know about but five hundred
thousand a week we've only done 500,000
to date right so you get a sense of how
powerful that would be if the FDA
approves that we're going to prioritize
the antibody testing for first
responders and essential workers and
this is important we've all been saying
thank you to the health care workers and
that's nice but I've been talking to
George Gresham through this is the head
of $11.99 which represents many
healthcare workers his point has always
been the gratitude is appreciated but we
need support the health care workers
need support they need the PPE equipment
and they need the tests to make sure
they're not getting infected or if they
are infected what is their status and
he's been exactly right
more than thank you actions more than
words right nurses the same thing knives
now they've been doing phenomenal work
they need support they need the
equipment they need time off they need
to recuperate and the first responders
the NYPD Pat Lynch who represents the
NYPD has said to me from day one
my guys need support has been gender
neutral they're out there every day they
live in the downstate area and they
worked in the downstate area many work
live in Nassau Suffolk Westchester
Rockland Orange and they're working in
New York City
they need not only PPE equipment etc
they need testing they need to know if
they've been infected for themselves and
also they could wind up being spreaders
if we don't know and Pat Lynch and the
NYPD have been extraordinary here
okay make them a priority for the
testing that we can do and we can
control and that's the antibody testing
and we will so the more testing the more
open the economy but there's not enough
national capacity to do this I've been
speaking to governor's across the
country every governor is now in the
same situation I was speaking with
governor Pritzker of Illinois he has
some companies that do this testing in
his state but everyone is in the same
position and we have to be clear on this
who does what between the federal
government and the state government the
states cannot develop national testing
there's no simple answer to it it's
basically controlled by private sector
companies who have been doing it at a
reduced volume because that was the
world
you didn't need such a high level of
tests so the private sector companies
only develop to the capacity that the
market demanded this is an entirely new
market and then when you talk to the
private sector companies which I have
they'll say I can't increase my volume I
can't get enough swabs I can't get
enough vials I don't have enough
machinery to manufacture it or test it
they meet chemical agents that do that
are part of the test
many of these chemical agents aren't
even manufactured in the United States
so there's an international supply chain
all this to say it is very hard to bring
this to scale quickly and we need the
federal government to be part of this
testing capacity to me is like what
ventilators were over the past month
all of a sudden because of this virus
and the respiratory attack we need
massive numbers of ventilators I never
heard about ventilators before this I
now know more than I ever wanted to know
about ventilators but it came out of the
blue they're very hard to manufacture
there's a whole supply chain they're a
sophisticated piece of equipment and you
just it's very hard to get them
manufactured quickly no one is to blame
on ventilators and own is to blame on
testing I know we're in a political
world well who's to blame who's to blame
somebody
sometimes there's nobody to blame you
know on this testing situation there's
nobody to blame just how do we now do it
how do you now scale this up and scale
it up quickly because we want to phase
the reopening as fast as we can between
now and a medical treatment and a
vaccine right that's what we're doing I
do know this is learning the lesson of
ventilators the answer on testing is not
what happened on ventilators which is 50
states competing against each other to
by testing capacity from these private
sector companies and the federal
government which is also buying testing
capacity competing against the 50 states
that is not learning the lesson of what
we did before so partnership with the
federal government 100% but we need that
partnership to do this once you test
then you have to trace the contacts so
we test Bernadette Bernadette turns up
positive ok who were you with over the
past week what family members were you
with who do you sit next to in the
office you now have a list of 30 people
if it's burned that even more because
she's highly so
sure has a lot of friends now somebody's
got to run down that list of 30 people
from one positive it's a detective
investigator in the public health space
that is a massive undertaking it's
intelligent but it's massive and that is
an army of tracers so testing I have to
get that up to scale and then tracing
yes but that's a massive undertaking
that we now don't do so testing tracing
isolation yes we have to do that in
concert with the federal government
again no one's done it before no one has
done it to this volume and second for
the states to do this role of reopening
we need funding and the past federal
legislation has not provided it it's
that simple they funded many good causes
hospitals more businesses etc yeah but
you now want the state governments to do
all this work do this to this to this to
this okay
I'll do everything I can I need your
help with the things I can't but you
have to provide funding because at the
same time the state governments are
broke and that's not just me that's
every governor in the United States
that's the National Governors
Association the Chairman governor Hogan
good man Republican and myself vice
chairman for the National Governors
Association wrote a joint letter saying
this states need five hundred billion
dollars in funding because I have to be
afloat and have some capacity to do all
these things you want the governor's to
now do and that has to be in the next
federal legislation and they can't be
excuses about it
so from today to 18 months
which is the last date for a vaccine
that's what we have to work through
first rule do no harm
this is a public health crisis we're
still in the woods and just because that
number has plateaued doesn't mean it's
any time to relax what we're doing so do
no harm
don't go backwards hope we find the
medical treatment between now and 18
months in the meantime testing tracing
testing tracing trying to get that up to
scale which is going to be the
equivalent of trying to get Apollo 13
back to earth 220,000 miles 50 years ago
it is a very difficult task it can't be
done perfectly I can tell you that right
now
but we can do better than we're doing
and at the main in the meantime a phased
reopening of the economy as educated by
testing tracing now one other point on
the phased reopening what does that mean
and how do we Fae is this reopening
until we get to a medical treatment or a
vaccine this is what we're thinking
about
we need clarity on what the federal
government is going to do and what the
state governments are going to do
I heard the president last night the
states it's up to the states basically
great I get it and the states can do to
do no harm it is their job to do the
public health monitoring the states can
also do the phased reopening plan we
cannot do the states that have a large
problem cannot do the testing and Tracy
without federal assistance and that's
important on the reopening we can do and
we have a blueprint for the reopening
again as
guided by testing tracing but there are
two factors really on the reopening how
essential is the business service or
product or function the more essential a
business service or product the more
urgent the need to immediately get them
back online or as soon as possible
so how essential is what the business
does and then second what is the risk of
infection spread of that business some
businesses can say I can open tomorrow
in my business I'll have all sorts of
precautions people will not be less than
six feet apart period there will be no
congregation of people I won't do
conferences I won't do joint meetings
it's not the way but my business
operates I can bring everybody back put
them at separate desks they'll never be
near each other I have a very low risk
of infection spread businesses can start
to redesign their workplace to think
that way all right so your business
poses a low risk of infection spread
that's the second factor and the first
factor is how essential is your business
so that is a almost a business by
business evaluation that has to go on
and then once you determine the
essential nature of the business because
right now we have all quote-unquote
essential workers who are working right
this would be well what's the next
tranche of essential workers and how
high or low is the possibility of
infection spread if that business
becomes operational and then you
basically have a matrix where the lower
risk of an infection spread and the
higher nature of essential services are
the businesses
you would start prioritizing right so
that's that's how we will inform our
economic reopening as we're being guided
by the testing tracing and as we're
making sure we're not jeopardizing the
success we've made in handling the
public health issue that's the whole
outline the whole vision from here to 18
months building that bridge to the new
normal for the economy until we get to a
conclusion in the meantime for today I
stopped the spread I'm going to show you
a chart in the next couple of days we've
been tracking the infection rate which
is what which is one person how many
people does one person in fact there's
one person in fact one person two people
three people that rate of infection is
the difference between a manageable
situation and a pandemic and they can
they can calibrate that for what wuhan
did where we are now and where we were
and it is a fascinating analysis but in
the meantime what do we do today we have
to continue to stop the spread and this
is a constant calibration also I'm going
to issue an executive order that says
all people in public must have a mask or
nose cover mouth and nose covering and
they must wear it in a situation where
you cannot or are not maintaining social
distancing meaning what meaning the same
thing we've been saying from day one if
you are going to be in public
and you cannot maintain social
distancing then have a mask and put the
mask on when you are not in socially
distant places you're walking down the
street you're walking down the street
alone
great you are now at an intersection and
there are people in the intersection and
you're going to be in proximity to other
people put the mask on your right to go
out for a walk in the park go out for a
walk because you need to get out of the
house the dog is getting on your nerves
fine don't infect me you don't have a
right to infect me if you are going to
be in a situation in public where you
may come into contact with other people
in a situation that is not socially
distanced you must have a mask or a
cloth covering nose and now that is by
executive order so if you're going to
get on public transit you're going to
get on a bus you're gonna get on a
subway you're gonna stand on a subway
platform you're going to walk in a
neighborhood that is busy you're gonna
be on a sidewalk you're going to pass
other people on a sidewalk you're not
going to be able to maintain social
distancing you must wear a mess or cloth
or an attractive bandanna or a
color-coordinated bandana flaw but you
have to wear it in those situations
we'll give people three day notice to
allow compliance just on the off chance
that somebody doesn't have a cloth
covering or a mask and we'll go from
there
on the ventilators we've stabilized our
healthcare situation New York had one of
the earlier curves
there are other places in this country
are now seeing increases in the death
rate and there seems stress on their
healthcare system I will never forget
the generosity that people of course
this country showed to our state and I
said at that time
New Yorkers are generous and they are
grateful and gracious and when you need
help we will be there for you and we
will be state of Michigan is going
through an issue right now state of
Maryland is going through an issue we're
stabilized we're going to send 100
ventilators to Michigan and 50 to the
state of Maryland last point personal
opinion build the bridge we built the
bridge and I learned a lot by building
that bridge and it's a lesson that has
informed me and a lesson that I think
should inform people who are hearing
about us needing to build this bridge it
was a bridge across the Hudson River
called the Tappan Zee Bridge it was in
very bad shape had been in very bad
shape for 20 years for 20 years
everybody talked about we're going to
replace the Tappan Zee Bridge nobody did
that means the bridge was in such bad
shape that there are actual holes in the
roadway that they would put these large
metal plates over and when you were
driving across the Tappan Zee you go
over one of these metal plates and the
plate would bounce a little bit and you
could actually see glimmers of light
that would come through the hole and the
metal plate traumatized two generations
of drivers me included and government
kept saying yeah we have to replace this
bridge we have to replace the bridge
never did I become governor I say we
have to replace the bridge oh raft the
bureaucrats say to me I mean that in a
nice way you know what it's too risky
adventure it goes across the Hudson
River the Hudson River is an
environmentally sensitive place you try
to build a bridge in the Hudson River
you have to put down piles do you have
to do all that construction it's going
to
no environmental concerns it's going to
be very expensive it's a very high-risk
difficult project and they cautioned me
not to do it and by the way for 20 years
nobody had done it I said yeah but then
you don't build the bridge I understand
the risk I'm saying you get blamed I
understand something could happen I
understand whatever you do in life
people are gonna have 57 different
opinions and it's never gonna be perfect
and yes they can always write stories
this one criticized this this one
criticized this love negative in society
for some reason but then you don't get
anything done long story short we built
the bridge on time on budget it's
beautiful we did go through all the
heartburn of going through a
construction project in the public
domain yes many people criticized we
picked blue they wanted green we did
this they wanted that that's the nature
of people but we did it we did it and it
is a beautiful symbol for me and for
anyone who sees it don't tell me that we
can't do it don't tell me we can't do it
because I know that we can do it because
we did do it and we did it very well
have we dealt with a situation like this
no can we build a bridge that takes us
from today to 18 months yes yes because
we are bridge builders that's what we do
we build bridges sometimes literally
sometimes symbolically sometimes
metaphorically but we build bridges the
bridges can be a bridge can be an
airport it can be a new civil rights
legislation it can be new labor rights
legislation new minimum wage legislation
but we build bridges that's what we do
in New York
and we're going to do this questions
Governor on the mask issue no so this
will be any public space where there is
congestion we're talking busy streets
stores what what we're just trying to
get thirty we need means any any
situation in public where you cannot
maintain social distancing six feet if
you can't maintain that social
distancing because you're going through
a congested area or it's a situation
where you can't maintain social distance
you cannot maintain social distancing on
public transit okay you can on the
street that is unoccupied but if you're
going out for a walk and you may come to
a place where you can't maintain social
distancing you have to have a mask the
there's a possibility for a civil
violation you could get a penalty
you know you jaywalked theoretically get
a penalty local governments would
enforce it I don't want to go to a
penalty yet I don't think it's we
haven't seen flagrant non-compliance so
there won't be a penalty I but it is an
executive order I'm directing if no one
if people don't follow it we could do a
civil penalty you're not gonna go to
jail for not wearing your mask but if we
get there but for now no there's no
civil penalty but local government
should start to enforce it and they
should come up and say you know Jesse
you're supposed to be wearing a mask and
by the way people will enforce it
they'll say to you if they're standing
next to you on a street corner where's
your mask buddy in a nice New York kind
of way
for New York to release the number of
coded cases and fatalities at individual
nursing homes two interests no two
interests one interest is release as
much data as possible we will release as
much data as possible on people who have
died in nursing homes second interest is
respect and legal rights to privacy you
pass away in a nursing home or your
parent passes away in a nursing home god
forbid should your parents picture
really be on the front page of the
newspaper the next day because they
passed away from kovat did that mean
their privacy should be violated and I
should release their name so that they
could be on the news that night you know
so that's the balance I've said to them
err on the side of more disclosure and
that's what they have been doing and
that's where they're going to continue
to do but don't discount person's right
to privacy about the death of a loved
one and your right to publicize that
death because you want to so it's a it's
a balance just remember no people are
maybe you're not but people are merit of
coordination do you have with the city
because mayor de Blasio said today you
go into a grocery store you have to wear
a mask that's his new order but did you
talk to him at all and also going back
to my question yesterday with those
homegrown tests you're talking about you
need federal assistance in order to
capacity and capability but if the city
is already trying to do that as well
how much are you working with those city
partners yeah Melissa can talk about the
overall coordination we have we have 400
local government officials in this state
this is statewide order I have 700
school districts I have 50 something
County executives we coordinate as much
as we can with everybody local
governments should and must be doing
what they think is necessary and then we
have statewide directives that everyone
should do because we have to have one
state plan right and then I have to turn
around and coordinate with New Jersey
and Connecticut and five other states so
we have to have one state plan and then
I try to coordinate down then I try to
coordinate up with the federal
government you know all this
coordination so you do the best you can
but when you have a statewide situation
which is what this is you have to have
rules that are statewide and we try to
coordinate with everyone they can have
their own rules
they just can't conflict with a
statewide rule that's the balance that's
the law so they can do anything they
want just they can't conflict there will
be times when they take a local action
which always which happens usually also
they take a local action the state then
takes an action the state action
overrides the local action whether it
was plastic bags or whatever you know a
lot of times we get into situations
where you have a lot of local laws
different local laws and then the state
takes an action which overrides the
local laws that's not just in this
situation this is just a more condensed
version of it so I don't know all the
local laws that are out there on masks
to tell you the truth and
as long as they don't conflict great but
if there's a conflict the state law
governs Bernadette I could just to
follow up on that so the details here
are obviously important what the gut
what the mayor announced yesterday was
that he's going to be moving to the new
testing system that they're gonna be
acquiring testing systems what he's
talking about is the swabs and the vials
that they go in what the governor is
talking about his testing capacity we've
been limited by the testing capacity in
the labs so there's two parts to that
there's the swabs that you use to
actually get the sample and then you
send it to the lab and you are
constrained by the testing capacity in
the lab so the governor's talking about
is increasing the capacities in the lab
and we are working hand in glove with
the city on that and all of our local
governments on the masks yes I've been
speaking to the city we're fully
supportive of what they said this
morning in grocery stores and we
discussed it and this was the next
logical step was to build on top of that
just so you understand testing and how
complex this is the first issue is you
can't bring it to scale but forget that
before you even get there you can't get
enough equipment testing equipment swabs
vials literally the the material that
you need when you talk to a private
sector company this is all done by
private sector companies when you talk
to them about how do you triple capacity
they'll say I can't get the swabs I
can't get the vials I can't get the
physical equipment that's one step
they'll then say I can't get the testing
agents the chemicals that they need to
do the actual testing they'll then say I
don't have the machines that can do the
testing so you have that whole supply
chain on top of it your people
contracting for tests all the states the
federal government local governments
cities counties towns all over the
country you then have private companies
that are trying to buy tests why because
I have my workers coming in and I
want to test my workers I'm an essential
service I'm a food manufacturer I have
200 employees they're going out to buy
tests to test that to what our employees
all of this volume is descending on
these private sector testing companies
that never anticipated this tremendous
volume so you're one of these testing
companies they're getting calls from
everybody private companies local
government States federal government I
need more I need more I need more so you
have this whole it's just a complicated
chaotic it is what ventilators was
probably even worse now can the federal
government do this no mistake let me do
it no can anyone do it no but we have to
do the best we can to try to figure out
how do you get the supply chain up where
do the chemicals come from what
countries do they come from and that has
to happen with the federal government I
don't know why the park was closed down
does anybody know there were complaints
from some local elected officials I
believe in Rockland County and so the
parks department evaluated the situation
and they decided to err on the side of
caution and so they've temporarily
closed the park our goal is to leave the
state parks open because as the governor
said we do want green space where people
can go and get fresh air and exercise
safely while they're able to social
distance so we're gonna evaluate that
situation and make a determination for
the long term but for the short term it
is closed
yeah look we can go back and do a
retrospective sometime when this is over
as I said I don't like to do Monday
Morning Quarterback when you're at
halftime because you're at halftime so
it's not really I don't know how this
turns out I don't know how it turns out
from New York I don't know how it turns
out for the nation so I just don't see
how you start to do a game review while
you're at the middle point of the game
if you forced me for a game review now I
would say yeah I'd like to know let's go
back to December January who was saying
what when where were where was the
international health community president
says where was the World Health
Organization this is not my world right
I don't know who should have done one
what went in january/february etc on the
New York which is a convenient fact that
people miss there is no state that moved
faster than the state of New York from
the time of our first case to starting
to shut down to total shutdown that all
happened in like nineteen days in the
state of New York we didn't have a case
early on remember this was Seattle state
of Washington California first it came
to the East Coast later but from time of
the first case to total shutdown New
York State was the shortest period of
time there were scuse me one second and
then we had steps in the middle between
first case and
total shutdown we did schools we did 25%
50% 75% but the whole thing was 19 days
and what you also have to remember is
and just as a matter of days on the
factual question of speed of the
movement no state moved faster than 19
days from first case to total shutdown
second point is it was not about my
declaring a total shutdown no one had
been here before and yeah I can sign an
executive order saying total shutdown
and the people of New York can say what
they would like to say which it said
nicely is I am NOT going to comply with
that because it's highly intrusive and
you have not shown me any need for that
action no I've moved faster than any
state in the nation
yeah we're not there yet
there is no civil penalty yet there is
no mandatory eviction from a public
transit yet
step one is turning before the way I
govern is I try to lay out the facts to
New Yorkers and then say this is what I
propose given the facts right started by
saying here are the facts it's not my
opinion just here were the facts then
I'll offer my opinion and you can throw
it out the window
throw it in the garbage pail then I'll
say this is what I proposed based on the
facts
I our success here has been the very
high compliance rate with a very
aggressive policy that came out of the
blue I mean just think what you're
asking people to do stay home and don't
go outside why would you ever believe
New Yorkers would comply with that I
think we were very effective at laying
out the facts and explaining why this
thing home not because I'm giving them a
ticket or because I am saying you'll go
to jail this thing home because they say
I heard you and it makes sense to me and
I'm doing it because it makes sense to
me so I haven't given anybody a ticket
for running a business I haven't given
anybody a ticket for violating anything
it's because they understood the facts
where I am now I'm saying here are the
facts stopping the spread is everything
how can you not wear a mask when you're
going to come close to a person on what
theory would you not do that now if they
don't accept that and there's widespread
non-compliance could we go to civil
penalty or could I say you can't be on
the trains or buses unless you wear a
mask you could get there I assume that's
what Philadelphia did if they said they
take your person off a train but we're
not there yet and I hope New Yorkers
will do it because it makes sense
[Applause]
a situation where they're scared not to
where they want to go on a run or a walk
and they don't think they'll see anyone
and they're worried about getting
ashamed for not wearing the mask people
even in this news conference
viewer they're writing I know so you
wear a mask you keep it below your chin
and then when you are running and you
come close to a person you either run
across the street or you put the mask up
over your mouth and nose so look it's
not the biggest thing to me in the world
right it doesn't have to be a surgical
mask it could be a cloth mask have it
with you and if you're in the walk in
the woods and you don't see anyone great
if you're in the walk in the woods and
here comes John Campbell and because
that's what he does a lot is walk in the
woods and you were having to run into
him then you have to put up your mask
because here comes John Campbell I think
when you think about look you get there
everybody's doing working so hard to
spread the disease the harm done if
someone gets the disease the number of
people impacted the health care workers
wear the mask what's the big deal
it can be a mask and be a cloth it can
be a bandana you can make it colorful
you can have a design make it
advertising what's the big deal right
risk reward is life
I think there's five to six hundred
Doc's workers who have now been infected
you know that's the prison system that's
that's parole some of them are nurses in
state hospitals so you have now a group
of state senators led by Tom O'Mara is
asking that you unfreeze that 2% so they
can see that tiny amount
their paychecks with that breakage ank
gho the bet it would break the bank you
know how you know how you know the bank
is broken that's how you know and the
state is broke and there's a lot of good
things I would like to do for a lot of
good people that we cannot do until we
have some financial stability and if
they want to help tell them call
Washington and tell Washington that you
neglected the state's financial needs in
the legislation you passed was wholly
disrespectful of the reality of the
situation and you know that state
governments are insolvent you know they
had to free pay to freeze pay increases
you know they had to take all sorts of
drastic measures they couldn't fund
education the way they wanted to provide
financial assistance to state
governments so they can do their work I
have to go to work
one of the main systems right we have
these snakes working together with AD to
coordinate are the systems in the
transportation you need economics school
system they all go together or none of
the years in terms unless all the gears
turn